you may have noticed the creepy porn
lawyer just got out of jail Michael
Cohen just got out of jail across the
country lettin rapists people who attack
children out of jail one person who's on
his way to jail may be the only one in
America is Roger stone two weeks he'll
be sentenced for the rest of his useful
adult life his crime supporting Donald
Trump how does he feel about that he
joins us now to explain Roger stone
thanks so much for coming on I'll just
get I'll just get right to it I'm a
little bit confused by why with all the
pardons going around everyone I've ever
met has been pardoned you haven't been
by a white house that has done a lot to
push criminal justice reform and let a
lot of really bad people out of jail in
the name of humanitarian concerns but
you're not in that category why is that
do you think well I really don't know
Tucker I was very hopeful that the
motion for a mistrial in my case based
on flagrant and blatant even egregious
juror misconduct would have won me a new
trial the US Supreme Court's been very
clear that all defendants are entitled
to a jury that is impartial and
indifferent but in this case it is
undisputable that the jury forewoman
attacked both me and President Trump in
2019 social media postings lied about
that during jury selection and then
later deleted her Facebook page to cover
her trails in this case legal
authorities ASDA versus Judge Andrew
Napolitano and professor John Turley
have both said that I should be entitled
to a new trial but that is not the case
so at this point the judge has ordered
me to surrender in two weeks and it's 67
years old with some underlying health
problems including a history of asthma I
believe with the coronavirus it is
essentially a death sentence well of
course it is they've already destroyed
your life it's the most corrupt
political criminal justice proceeding
I've ever seen Bob Dylan should be
writing a song about you and yet
you can't get a pardon because your
crime was worse than raping someone you
supported Trump are you bitter I'm not
but I would like I'm glad after 16
months of being gagged to finally at
least be able to defend myself
Tucker I wasn't prosecuted because I was
covering anything up for the president
I was prosecuted because I refused to
bear false witness against the president
I refused to dissemble as the
prosecutors wanted about numerous phone
calls between myself and candidate Trump
in 2016 so at this junk juncture I am
praying for justice I am praying for
mercy but I've got to be honest with you
it's in God's hands after after meeting
and praying with Reverend Franklin
Graham some months ago I have
reacquainted myself with my Catholic
faith my Christian faith Rodger studying
for the very best